nuevamente llegó esta época del año y el
e3 se acerca de nuevo tendremos
múltiples conferencias para ver qué
juegos serán los que nos depara el
futuro y en cuáles decidiremos gastar
nuestros ahorros esta época del año está
cargada de contenido de parte de las
desarrolladoras ya que el e3 es el lugar
donde se muestran los juegos en los que
cada compañía está trabajando para el
futuro además de los proyectos como el
nuevo xbox y playstation 5 ciertamente
este será un año un poco extraño para el
e3 porque por desgracia soy no estará
presente en ninguna conferencia así que
por ahora no podemos esperar noticias ni
station 5 costosísima la segunda parte
de las copas ni siquiera de standing
crear nuevos que yo más quería ver
[ __ ]
pero a pesar de esto tenemos muchos
títulos y cosas asombrosas en este e3
así que veamos por eso los anuncios que
más esperan en las conferencias de este
año
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y claro esta lista no puede comenzar de
otra manera que con sauber pon 2077 ya
que será uno de los grandes
protagonistas de este e3 este rpg en
primera persona lleva años en desarrollo
siendo uno de los proyectos más
ambiciosos de la desarrolladora seed y
project red en el e3 del año pasado nos
mostraron un tráiler con un gameplay que
no todos emocionados con su ambientación
futurista pero llena de crimen y ahora
las expectativas no han hecho nada más
que subir gracias a que todas las
personas que han visto el nuevo a puerta
cerrada aseguran que es asombroso siendo
uno de los juegos más esperados para las
conferencias de 2019 para este año
espero que ya tengamos un nuevo tráiler
o con suerte una demo jugable y por fin
una fecha de lanzamiento
[Música]
después del sabor agridulce que nos dejó
con star wars bar fondo todo parece
indicar que quieren reivindicarse con
este nuevo título de star wars que por
lo que parece hasta el momento promete
llega y fue en order es un juego del que
sabemos muy poca cosa pero lo poco que
sí sabemos luce bien porque después del
fiasco que fue para el front 2 y ella al
parecer aprendió de sus errores y está
descree concentrarse más en un juego de
modo solitario dejando el multijugador a
un lado contando con mecánicas de
combate mano a mano cercanas sobre la
historia sólo sabemos que tratará de un
joven que sobrevivió a la orden 66 y que
tratará de hallar su camino como yeda y
la historia del juego al parecer se
relacionará con el logre de las
películas así que todos los es bastante
bien por el momento electronic arts no
ir al e3 de este año pero ya confirmó
que este juego sí se verán algunas las
conferencias probablemente en la y
microsoft así que habrá que aguardar a
este mes para más detalles
[Música]
hasta se excluirá pasar por momentos
difíciles pero con sus últimos juegos
siendo bastante buenos para secar
retomar en el camino de nuevo después de
lujo con egipto y otro en grecia los
seguidores de esta franquicia están en
la espera de ver cuál será el siguiente
paso que tomara ubisoft para este nuevo
título lo más sonado hasta ahora es que
luego hace se escribe tendrá una
ambientación vikinga y su posible fecha
de estreno será 2020 pero cualquier
nueva información de manuel ubisoft será
bienvenida
en 2015 fue arreglado el remake de final
fantasy 7 y todos estamos entusiasmados
sobre eso pero es de que se reveló las
cosas para hacer empezaron a ir más
lento en el desarrollo y todo sobre el
juego al parecer se estaba yendo
lentamente al [ __ ] ya que por alguna
razón después de un tiempo se dejaron de
dar noticias de este remake pero después
de tanto tiempo y con el auge y éxito
que están teniendo los remakes en estos
meses el e3 de este año parece la
oportunidad perfecta para retomar la
atención de los fanáticos de este tan
esperado remake
i
desde la salida de racing y bulldog
remake ya todo el mundo está esperando
actualmente que anuncien oficialmente el
remake del tercer juego y con éxito que
tuvo el más reciente river y con la
acogida de tanto fans como crítica es de
esperarse que capcom de luz verde al
juego en la conferencia de este año como
en un vídeo anterior capcom se está
centrando en dos juegos por momento
recién y 18 y el remake de némesis no lo
están dedicando más tiempo a recibe
nivel 8 así que lo que podemos esperar
es que en un sin primero recién nivel 3
rime la única duda que queda es saber si
lo anuncian este año o el siguiente si
quieres escuchar todos los rumores y
datos que saben de res y de nivel 3
remake y racing el 8 aquí tengo un vídeo
para despejar tu curiosidad
[Música]
i
ya hace dos años que square enix anunció
que está trabajando en los juegos los
vengadores con el nombre provisional de
proyecto avengers' pero después de eso y
un muy breve teaser no hemos había
absolutamente nada del juego claro que
rumores hay muchos como que puede que
sea un juego multijugador en tercera
persona con combate e incluso secciones
de sigilo pero no tenemos que asignar
información del título propio néstor the
avengers en game aún bastante reciente y
la emoción por los vengadores aún a flor
de piel
este pare desde el momento justo para
que square enix nos dé más información
del juego
y
para sorpresa de muchos es la primera
vez en años que no sabemos casi nada el
siguiente call of duty desde que se tomó
la decisión de dejar descansar la
franquicia en vez de sacar un título
anual la saga ha mejorado bastante y
ahora después de black ops 4 parece que
ya está preparando un nuevo call of duty
actuando como un reboot de la franquicia
esta multitud lo traerá de vuelta el
modo campaña al parecer enfocándose en
el terrorismo actual a mí en lo personal
con los de ti es una saga que me gusta
eso que tenía pero me llama la atención
sobre todo pulmón zombies me encanta la
historia y la jugabilidad de zombies en
carla bruti pero esperemos que pronto
podamos saber más de este nuevo título
[Música]
y siguiendo con la lista tenemos a dos
exclusivos de xbox que si lo realizan de
buena manera serán excelentes comenzando
por guiones tactics este será un juego
ambientado en el universo de killer
software pero alejado del shooter en
tercera persona que todos conocemos este
juego se centrará más en la estrategia
con el modo de juego y características
muy parecidas a la saga ex com recuerda
presumir de excelente la verdad este
refresco le viene bien tanto aquí es
como la xbox teniendo un nuevo y
atractivo exclusivo a base de encaja muy
bien esta temática de estrategia en un
universo como el de gears
ahora que quiero jugar paso de epic
games al equipo de edición todo parece
indicar que el 5 quiere tomar un rumbo
algo nuevo después del cuarto juego y
ahora que son y no acudir al e3 de este
año es la oportunidad de microsoft de
liderar las conferencias con sus
exclusivos no hay mejor manera que con
su exclusivo insignia que ahora tendrá
su quinta parte así que este año podemos
esperar un tráiler algo más de gameplay
y una fecha de lanzamiento
[Música]
halloween fini esta casa seguro que será
uno de los centros de atención de todo
el evento ya que es un juego que se ha
prometido llegar a revolucionar el
concepto de los juegos de halo y sobre
todo enmendar los errores del quinto
juego que dejó tanto que desear ya que
la conferencia de microsoft será las más
importantes en mucho tiempo es casi
seguro que halo infinite será el cierre
del evento dando más información sobre
este proyecto
[Música]
y
a pesar de que es poco probable que
pasen ya que capcom está ocupada con
otros juegos un robot de dino crisis no
estaría nada mal como sorpresa de este
año con el lento resurgimiento del
survival foro que estamos viendo estos
años sería algo genial ver este clásico
del terror reimaginado y adaptado a
actuales generaciones a pesar de lo poco
probable que parezca ya ha habido
bastantes rumores de personas cercanas a
capcom que dice que la idea se estaba
considerando así que hay que esperar lo
mejor
[Música]
en jazz de yuri es un estudio que ha
demostrado lo valioso que es con el paso
del tiempo y ahora aprovechando que
microsoft adquirió este estudio y que se
anunció que están trabajando en un nuevo
título podemos esperar grandes cosas de
los creadores de head late oficialmente
no se hizo nada pero podemos esperar que
en julio tengamos más información una
decisión algo cuestionable de parte de
ubisoft es que decidieron revelar el
nuevo récord antes del e3 lo cual es
algo inusual pero al menos ya tenemos
mucha información de este nuevo título
ghost recon break point es una secuela
directa a wise lines en donde lucharemos
contra un grupo de agentes renegados que
gobernarán una isla con drones a su
disposición esta isla haciendo un nuevo
mapa el cual podemos explorar con un
mundo abierto pero interesantes del
nuevo bold record es que introducirá las
mecánicas de las heridas y la estamina
creando lear un enfoque más realista el
título a mí en lo personal me parece que
es el juego de una pinta genial y me
gustó mucho todo lo que demostrar hasta
el momento espero que pronto podamos ver
más del juego por momento la fecha de
salida del juego es del 4 octubre de
este mismo año
i
recientemente un desarrollador de
ubisoft por error de lo que están
trabajando en un nuevo splinter cell lo
cual estoy seguro que era muy feliz a
los fans splinter cell es una de mis
sagas favoritas y su última entrega
black list a pesar de que no fue muy
bien recibida me encantó últimamente
volví a jugar está enganchado de nuevo
porque traerán de vuelta a esta
franquicia tan genial y memorable es
algo que me hará a mí ya muchos otros
fans de splinter cell ver con mucha más
emoción y expectación el e3 de este año
sam fisher fue un icono de los juegos de
espionaje realizando en su tiempo con
solid snake y ahora que es nike se
retiró y no saben nada de metal gear un
nuevo juego espionaje y sigilo de la
talla con splinter cell será una de las
mayores sorpresas del evento
i
[Música]
sé que esto no es un juego como tal pero
no puede acabar el vídeo hablando de
otra cosa que no fuera la xbox scarlett
sabiendo que el rival de microsoft son y
no acudir al evento dejándole hacia xbox
el camino libre en el e3 este es un
momento excelente para desvelar y
anunciar formalmente la nueva generación
de consolas en la que microsoft ya está
trabajando estos últimos años ya son
varias las noticias que aseguran que la
nueva xbox era revolucionaria y
mantendrá el título de la consola más
potente del mundo además de esto sumando
el proyecto es cloud es como una nube en
xbox por así decirlo las probabilidades
de que ésta una consola aparezcan en el
e3 son muy altas estoy muy emocionado
por ver una generación de consolas de
parte de microsoft pero único que no
quiero es que el modelo inicial no dure
en la generación actual tuvimos muchas
versiones de xbox el xbox one one s/n
quisiera la xbox one digital espero que
este no generación de consolas no
presente tantos problemas pero
independientemente de ello esperemos que
la gran sorpresa de microsoft en sus
conferencias sea el anuncio oficial de
esta nueva consola
bueno eso ha sido todo por ahora sin
duda alguna el e3 de este año luce muy
prometedor con tantos proyectos a la
expectativa y cosas por esperar por
ahora habrá que ver qué nos depara junio
para todos nosotros la cuenta regresiva
hacia el estrés cada vez se hace más
corta se creen que faltó algún juego
anunció en este vídeo deben saber en los
comentarios y también por qué no
comenten cuáles son los proyectos que
más esperan hasta la próxima
cómo
[Música]
i
a
[Música]